hey leute und willkommen zu einer neuen
mod vorstellung diesmal von dem mord
super pilz mord dieser mod fügt keine
pilze hinzu habe der witzig sondern
effekt legale minecraft drogen in eure
welt hinzu die anhand von pillen in
eurem inventar verfügbar sein werden
mit diesen bildern könnt ihr dann unter
anderem höher springen schneller laufen
seit stärker seit unsichtbar und sobald
er noch ganz ganz viele andere sachen
und wie ihr genau das macht und wie ihr
euch das kräfte zeige ich euch gleich
guckt nicht so blöd also ich zeige euch
jetzt mal ganz kurz wie ihr euch die
verschiedenen pillen kraft hat und
welche es da eigentlich gibt es gibt die
superpole die alles mögliche hinzufügt
was ich euch aber nachher noch genauer
erklären werde
die könnt ihr so kraft indem wir da
redstone in die äußeren teile in die
mitte von dem redstone diamant mit in
die mitte zucker dann gibt es die super
jump bilder also die super spring pille
auch wieder außen redstone dazwischen
diesmal zucker anstatt jemand in die
mitte einen schleier ball dann gibt es
den superspeed also die super super
speed pillen mein gott kommission an
diese pille ist halt dafür da dass ihr
ganz ganz schnell laufen könnt einfach
außen klostern und überall sonst zucker
dann gibt es hier die super strength
will also damit seid ihr total stark
damit einfach wieder außen redstone
dazwischen eisen in die mitte zucker
dann gibt es die super die linke also
damit könnt ihr euch heilen aber die hat
einen interessanten nebeneffekt einfach
nach außen wieder redstone dazwischen
rohes schweinefleisch kein anderer
schweinefleisch kein anderes kein
anderes merken und in die mitte zucker
und dann gibt es zu guter letzt noch die
super am opel die hat außen goldbarren
in der mitte dazwischen eisenwaren und
da zucker und was diesen film am
inventar sucht das weise nicht die habe
ich zwei mal drin denn es spart
nachdem ich euch nun gezeigt habe wie
ihr diese pillen kräfte kann ich euch
nur mal kurz die wirkung und die
anwendung dieser pillen erklären und
zwar müsst einfach rechtsklick machen
dann könnt ihr die einnehmen und ich
würde sagen empfangen einfach mal mit
der super jumpin an einfach rechtsklick
da seht ihr fehle macinga also ich fühle
mich wundervoll
also so der typische einfluss von drogen
ihr seht ich habe eine sprung
verstärkung einer resistenz das heißt
wenn ich jetzt einmal auf space drücke
fliege ich unglaublich hoch und ich
bekomme auch keinen schaden also das
könnt ihr auch im wie heißt es im ort
ausprobieren also bekommt keinen schaden
bei dir einfach resistenz habt und alles
mögliche also ihr könnt sagt
hochspringen seit hier oben mit einmal
springen und dann seid ihr wieder runden
die nächste bill ist die superspeed pill
einfach mal essen
das ewo wird sich ein bisschen geändert
die sachen sind nun deutlich weiter
auseinander
und wenn ihr ganz normal läuft ich zeige
euch das nicht auf ganz normalen und ihr
läuft schon extrem schnell extrem
schnell ist und wenn ich dann auch noch
sprinter ist das noch mal ganz ganz ganz
ganz viel schneller und das ist echt
krass wenn ihr mal so spielt oder so
dass es bei horror mailing amazing
amazing predigt auf englisch und das
andere in verbindung mit dieser dass das
ist und die nächste welle ist die super
strength will dafür musste ich aber mal
ganz kurz game zu null so ich hätte
diese pille und ihr seht ich muss noch
einmal auf einen block drauf drücken und
dann bräuchte ich schon ab das heißt
wartet da stärke und stärke habe ich
alle habe ich da auch noch mit drin
das heißt wenn ich einmal auf einen
block wurf clique ist der sofort
abgebaut moment wenn ich auf tiere
draufdrücken töte ich die damit auch
direkt beim ersten mal also das hat echt
eine menge vorteile wenn ihr einfach
ganz schnell liegende fläche abbauen
wollt oder so betrachtet wie man das wie
man das crafted habe ich euch auf euren
schon gezeigt von daher würde ich sagen
machen wir direkt meister weiter mit der
nächsten pille und zwar ist dass die
super die linke das ist ich muss mal
kurz den ganzen dreck hier aus dem bau
nicht nur ihr weg weg weg weg weg weg so
wenn ich die es so dann werde ich
geheilt also ihr seht ihr herzen unten
die klappern aber das ist der
nebeneffekt mein bildschirm verschwimmt
und wenn ich laufe ist das so
schrecklich es ist einfach so
schrecklich wenn ich dazu noch irgendwie
springe oder so dass es
irgendwie musste ich doch nicht kürzen
aber das ist doch eigentlich ganz gut da
können wir direkt weiter machen und zwar
mit der super amokläufe der super
rüstungs pille die ist aus ananas
wenn ich die jetzt mal ecke und dann
hier skelettes tonne schießen die mich
zwar ab allerdings weniger als sonst und
ihr seht mein leben geht gar nicht
runter also 20 sekunden lang habe ich
die drei sachen sage ich mal
egal ob die mich abschießen oder nicht
mein leben geht einfach nicht runter ich
bin quasi total stark und was auch ist
ich bin total langsam und für ein paar
mops auch unsichtbar
also ein paar mops sehen mich nicht zum
beispiel kripo oder so die
explodierenden nicht und so weiter also
sind schon ein paar interessante
wirkungen natürlich das hier ist jetzt
blöd dass ich jetzt langsam war aber ist
halt der blöde nebeneffekt jetzt bin ich
wieder raus und jetzt kommen wir zur
letzten fehler der superpole die wollte
ich mir extra bis zum ende auf bewahren
weil die fügt einfach alles hin zu
beziehen wir fast alles ich kann ganz
schnell laufen ich kann hoch springen
kann mir dabei auch nicht wehtun wenn
ich wieder runter falle welcher dieses
wir heißt es resistenz klopp ich war es
denn feuer resistenz alles mögliche das
heißt egal von wo ich hoch springe ich
kann quasi mir passiert gar nichts und
ich bin halt total schnell natürlich
nicht so schnell wie bei dass die pille
das knochenstück schneller aber dafür
gibts halt an die speed die superpole
ist einfach die pille die von allem ein
bisschen was hinzufügt und so leute das
war jetzt mit diesem motto ich denke
hier noch ein bisschen vor mich immer
sehr schrecklich wie immer wenn euch das
wort gefallen hat beziehungsweise das
video würde ich mich über einen daumen
hoch freuen
ihr könnt übrigens auch in die
kommentare neue mods vorstellen die
vielleicht das nächste mal vorstellen
sollte ihr von mir reviewed sehen wollt
ich hoffe jetzt noch ein bisschen rum
der downloadlink von mod facebook
twitter und so weit dass alles unten in
der beschreibung ich würde mich freuen
wenn das nächste mal auch wieder
einschaltet und dann würde ich sagen
noch ein schönes leben mit diesem motto